la commanderie d'elancourt ouvre à
nouveau ses portes la saison sera lancée
samedi de 17h à minuit par un moment de
partage et de festivités avec pour mot
d'ordre les retrouvailles on a tellement
hâte de vraiment relancer une nouvelle
saison qui on l'espère va se dérouler au
mieux mais de retrouver aussi les
artistes et nos intervenants qu'on n'a
pas trop vu depuis un an et demi pour
l'occasion l'intégralité de l'espace
extérieur de la commanderie sera occupée
il suffit de faire un petit retour en
arrière pour avoir un aperçu de la
soirée on va avoir d'abord un tout une
partie entre 17h et 20h de différentes
propositions artistiques en continu dire
comme ça voilà avec du théâtre avec la
compagnie des filles simone avec de la
jonglerie avec des impromptus dans ces
deux-là de la compagnie cfb 451 et puis
après on a donné carte blanche arthur
pérol chorégraphe de la compagnie f pour
me concocté tout un programme de 20
heures à minuit
la soirée se clôturera en dansant avec
la présence d'un dj un programme
d'ouverture complet qui laisse présager
d'une saison 2021 2022 tout aussi
mouvementé l'idée c'est de faire vivre
ce lieu avec vraiment toutes sortes de
propositions en sciences on danse en art
et tous les publics sur tout ce qui est
important aussi pour nous c'est
d'accueillir du plus jeune au plus vieux
de croiser les publics aussi parmi les
grandes dates de ce début de saison les
journées du patrimoine les 18 et 19
septembre la nuit blanche le 2 octobre
prochain et le village de la science les
9 et 10 octobre